thank you very much I would like to
first thank the conference organizers
for their invitation to speak I would
like to thank them for having the
wonderful animation with the countdown
this is the first time I think I have
ever spoken at a conference on time it's
usually just 60 seconds or 90 but when
you have as many slides as I have they
matter so let's get into it what is a
limiting case from the title of my talk
a limiting case is what happens when you
get a series of options and take them
all the way to their extreme an example
is a polygon of insides three is a
triangle four is a square five is a
Pentagon as n goes to infinity and those
sides become smaller and smaller and
more numerous the shape becomes a circle
thus a circle is said to be the limiting
case of the set of regular polygons it's
what happens if you take the idea to its
extreme I would like to argue or
describe Python as a limiting case of
C++ if you get all of the good ideas in
C++ and simply clean them up by taking
them to their extreme I will argue that
you naturally get Python as a result
just as the circle Falls quite naturally
out of the end of the series of polygons
I got interested in Python because in
the 1990s I was undergoing a period I
will say of divestment I was getting
tired of things IARC used for example
anyone remember IR cues anyone remember
IR queue jumpers anyone remember reading
guides on how to make the IR cues on
like your graphics card lower than on
your disk so that your games graphics
would run faster
I got tired of Malick Inge and freeing
things around the same time that I
stopped going in and setting the jumpers
to manually tweak the IARC use on my
machines both happened roughly around
1997 uh there's this point where you're
new at things and you want to control
all the knobs and then some people
remain fascinated forever with the knobs
I have a personality where I often once
I kind of get the point I'm happy to
have a machine take over some of the
responsibilities of assigning IR cues
and I also was interested in language
looking around in the late 90s that
would let me get on with the process of
modeling a domain and solving problems
in it rather than worrying about where
the computer had stashed my information
in RAM how could we simplify C++ but
without repeating the sins of the old
scripting languages I don't know if you
know any of them scripting language I
will just here to fine for the purposes
of this talk as a language that takes
the sources input you give it the source
and it may be internally does a
compilation step but it goes ahead and
runs it without which means that as the
program is running the compiler is still
there because you run the compiler it
loads the source does something with it
and then starts it running it's still
there in the background most famously in
scripting languages where most of them
support eval the ability to construct a
string that wasn't there that didn't
exist maybe you assemble it it didn't
exist when the the program source code
and you asked for it to be freshly
evaluated Lexton tokenized and compiled
and run as an instance of the language
Python just for fun it doesn't have to
most scripting languages don't it also
goes ahead and lets you get into the
low-level tokenizer
make syntax highlighter is really really
easier right if you don't have to break
the text into symbols and it also lets
you get into the AS
which makes certain kinds of linters
extremely easy to write a lot of the
pieces of a language ecosystem that
often you have to do without are
built-in in Python we'll talk about that
a little later so let's say we're going
to build something from the ground up
what should we do with its syntax we do
not want to make the mistakes of some
other scripting languages I remember I
was never able to use Perl can you see
why it's that dollar sign I knew
immediately that Perl didn't know how
computer languages work the reason that
you put dollar signs when you say you
know echo dollar sign name so a Hello
dollar sign user and bash the reason the
dollar sign is there is to mark dollar
sign user a special somehow because bash
also supports you just typing literal
words echo and hello but once you make
the grand Copernican revolution and
entering real computer programming where
strings live inside of little quotes and
don't display themselves out across your
file the privilege of being a real
programming language is the dollar sign
goes away it's noise it's ugly it
doesn't need to be there if there aren't
other words that the variable names
could be confused with so I was never
able to get started with Perl if we're
going to design a programming language
that's for serious programming we can't
have little dollar signs what are we
going to do syntax
let's use seas I mean it works pretty
well right let's have assignment be an
equal sign wasn't what all languages
chose but people are used to it now but
let's not make it an expression let's
not let people many of these people will
be scientists and schoolchildren
it's not always the schoolchildren that
are worse programmers it's going to be
scientists and schoolchildren using a
general-purpose language let's not let
the mutate state in the middle of an
expression let's promote assignment to
being a statement if you're going to
change the set of values you're
currently working with that deserves to
be up at the top level so you can read
down the left-hand column of a function
and see when it adjusts the value of
each of its variables what should be
used for equivalence if we've already
used the equal sign for something that
didn't mean equals will do what see did
everyone's used to that plus minus
multiply will just steal all of the
bitwise and arithmetic operators because
they work fine and everyone is happy
with them we will have a little bit of
fun of course what do you think of when
you think of the percent sign you think
think of string interpolation of course
it just so happens to the modulo
operator had a vacancy it wasn't defined
on strings so we will go ahead and build
in inter string interpolation into any
expression you want to use it in by
using the percent sign it will even be
easy to remember we will have number
numeric expressions in different bases
work exactly like in C because everyone
understands C strings we will use
backslashes just like C are you
beginning to see the pattern control
flow what if we used if-else while break
and continue fairly obvious meanings
everyone's used to them it will make the
language easy to use
we will co-opt for to immediately be the
iterator or range based pattern that
that only has arrived in C++ more
recently but Python from the beginning
had this syntax for is what you use
instead of a while loop to hide the math
the iteration the linked list or the
incrementation used to deliver to you
all of the items in a data structure
whose details you don't need to know if
the for loop in kind and talking with
the data structure it's figuring out
what to do
we will keep from C++ exceptions and
exception handling that will make them
vastly cheaper so they can be used as
normal parts of processing we will make
item lookup a little fancier by
supporting slicing we're instead of
asking for one item you can ask for a
substring or a sub part of an array
using a colon ah and we will fix the
original problem with C of the trailing
comma the story starts starts with
Pascal the horrible language that used
semicolon not as a statement terminator
but as a statement separator that meant
that you had to put a semicolon at the
end of every statement but the last it
was a syntax error to put a semicolon on
the last statement because it had no
further statement to be separated from
that's the difference between a
separator and a terminator and it meant
that whenever you tried to cut and paste
and move lines around your Pascal
program turned into a syntax error until
you went in and took the semicolon off
the last line and put it on the one
you've moved
knr see they were far better about
statements and they made semicolon a
terminator creating that beautiful
symmetry where every single statement
has a semicolon so you can move them
around Oh laughs then they dropped the
ball they made comma in static
initializers a mere separator which
looks fine as long as everything fits on
one line looks quite normal
but as soon as your initializer gets
tall enough that you switch it to
vertical you now have the same asymmetry
problem from Pascal Python was very
early in making the knot the statement
semicolon but the comma data separator
optional at the very end of the list if
you want to include it for symmetry
now Python made it completely optional
in either context you can leave it off
horizontally or vertically or you can
put it in horizontally or vertically
completely up to you it can make it
easier by the way for a program to
generate the text you know if you're
doing code generation it actually makes
it easier to generate that top line if
there's a comma after everything this
did later come into c99 in C++ 11 the
optional comma interestingly enough go
is very persnickety have any of you used
go one person has it ever complained at
you about something that you typed go
actually doesn't doesn't make it
optional if everything fits on one line
it's illegal to have the trailing comma
if you switch things to vertical it
becomes mandatory after all I guess Rob
Pike said if it's a good idea you should
always do it another thing that we
should bring over into the scripting
language we're designing is namespaces
they're critical they're crucial they
prevent the old nightmare of link time
collisions of of symbols that if you
didn't write all whole libraries in
question can be very difficult to
resolve but we're going to do it more
slim simply we're not going to let you
arbitrarily name your namespaces they
will have the name of the file if you
write a file pupu dot pi it is by
definition a Python module and the name
of that module is foo we're going to be
even simpler we're going to go down to
only having one namespace operator if I
have a directory my package a file my
module inside of which is a class and
then it has an attribute
it is my package dot my module dot C dot
read a universal operator which works on
all namespaces because after all it's
basically just busywork to have to
remember to use different operators to
do the same operation looking in a
namespace for a name
don't worry that doesn't mean in your
Python programs that you're going to
make you use the fully qualified name
for a symbol like read we will have
several versions of the import statement
that bring a module or its symbol in
that module into your namespace that let
you vary the amount of specificity the
amount of fully qualified nough stew the
names to wherever on the fully qualified
miss meter you want them this means that
automatically without a single
declaration to load functions defined in
different modules automatically are
unable to ever collide the fact that
every module is its own global namespace
and call the module Global's means that
static goes away we don't need to
there's no reason to be conservative and
keep things out of that namespace and it
wouldn't be meaningful since all modules
aren't sharing a namespace we do have a
little hat tip to one function static
used to perform which is that if you put
an underscore in front of a name in a
module it advertises to your fellow
programmers that they shouldn't touch it
it's internal only for internal use no
promise that it will keep working in the
future and also IDE editors
tab-completion
won't ever show anything that starts
with a tab when you are programming
we're not gonna bring over function
overloading function overloading is very
very complicated and we're going to
solve the main problem it applies to
more simply we're going to allow
optional arguments which have a default
so you don't have to specify them and
keyword arguments that let you jump over
all the defaults you want to keep in
order to change one that you want to
adjust this means that you don't have to
write you know two to the end different
versions of a function to handle all of
the different combinations of arguments
someone could want to give it and more
importantly if you want to answer the
question which write CSV did I just call
well we don't do function function
dispatch it will be the single write CSV
that you can go find in that py file
with a simple search we're going to do
something though radical for scripting
languages we are going to give full
access to raw UNIX system calls I don't
know why scripting languages so often
wanted to have their own little quirky
ways to open a socket they would have
these strange little script way language
ways of trying to let you do socket
operations and somehow they never got
around to implementing all of them they
would do the 5 or 6 they understood and
leave the rest off Python instead in the
basic modules that let you interact with
the OS copies in every single standard
in this case socket function system call
and this means that you can open your
Stevens programming in the UNIX
environment book and pretty much just
copy the calls into Python and your
pipes your sub processes your Forks your
execs and your sockets work exactly as
advertised
I don't know ghido could have done this
the early contributors could have done
this just because they were lazy but it
had a magnificent effect that you could
transfer a knowledge from C C++ directly
into Python because they hadn't bothered
to try to re-explain how you should
create sockets and this was magnificent
talk didn't let me create sockets I
don't remember tickle letting me do it
pearl had some crazy way this just
looked like sea having borrowed a number
of things though there are a few things
we're going to fix as we construct this
simpler language undefined behavior
unspecified behavior and implementation
to find behavior are bad ideas for a
language that physicists data scientists
and schoolchildren are going to be using
and very often the gains you get are
fairly tiny for allowing that we will
instead decree that every Python program
that is syntactically valid has a unique
meaning that is the same on all
platforms by in the standard putting
things like we evaluate expressions left
to right instead of doing it in a random
order that we rolled on a die or
something
and this means that there is always a
unique meaning interpretation and order
of operations for every expression you
can write if you happen to know it might
go faster in another order you can put
them in another order but you're in
control of the order that the program
executes all right we're going to need
to fix the precedence I don't know if
you've ever done this before wanting to
know if from the old set of flags and
the new set of Flags you kept the hex 80
bit the same if you've ever tried
writing this you very quickly discovered
that C thinks of this as oh let's
compare in flags to hex 80 and then get
the resulting 1 or 0 and and it with
both a flags and hex 80 giving 0
Oh see we're going to fix that switch
the priorities the equivalents and in
equality operators come after all of the
arithmetic operators meaning that the
top expression is interpreted by Python
as the bottom one eliminate a source of
errors their readability is important
while plus and minus are familiar to
people from math class
they might not ever have seen double
ampersand before so we are going to use
words and an or so that instead of
staring at symbols people are to the
extent possible staring at words that
they recognize and as a bonus we're
gonna make them short-circuit just like
in C++ but instead of returning 1 or 0
this always gets me when I come back to
C++ we're going to return the last value
that was evaluated so you can say if
you're afraid that error dot message
might be an empty value you can say
error dot message or the string error
and you will have returned to you the
first one of those that is true we're
going to extend C's good idea that zero
is false two empty strings and
containers that we will judge the truth
of our falsehood of which by their
length it's all zeroes and empty data
structures all if you could cast them to
bool are considered false so you can say
if not my list if you want to see
whether the list as anything in it
we are going to eliminate entirely
because this is supposed to be
consistent easy to use language all
concept of integer overflow in some
languages if you get certain large
integers suspiciously close to two
billion and add one to them you get a
negative number instead of a slightly
larger number that's upwards of two
billion we are instead going to
implement injured integers so that they
always behave like integers rather than
you know numbers in some sort of modulo
Groundhog Day loop after all if this
language is going to be used by
physicists by mathematicians by
statisticians a physicist deserves if
they ask what 2 to the 250 7th power is
to get a big number come on computers
are good at numbers this is basic stuff
and so we are going to have an integer
type that always always always behaves
until the size of the integer exhausts
Ram we now come to the huge question
with a scripting language and this is
the thing that I think in pythons early
days might have kept its momentum up
when it was very very small and
popularity compared to things like Perl
but the type system be looser strict
how many people here have ever written
JavaScript what is the string digit 4
minus the integer value 3
excellent it is one what is the digit
for string plus 343 not even the number
43 but the string this is a loose type
system this is a language that has some
kind of inferiority complex and is
afraid that you're going to judge it if
it can't cast and recast and recast the
values you've given it until it comes up
with something for some reason it thinks
you're perfect if you asked to add a
string and a number you must know what
you're doing and obviously it's its
fault if you can't find some way to cast
that to an answer problem is it so
rarely the answer you wanted what is an
empty array plus an empty array in
JavaScript once all of the dust has
settled in the casting is over
exactly it's empty string in JavaScript
all right we're going to try different
types here what happens if you get the
empty array and add it to the empty
object yes it's the string object object
in brackets with a second one
capitalized all right
addition we usually think of as
commutative commutative what if we swap
it around and put the object first yes
it is 0 if that amused you you should go
see the talk Blues in 2012 a little
five-minute lightning talk by Gary
Bernhardt called rat which consists of a
crowd laughing uproariously as he goes
through Ruby and JavaScript many
examples and then comically says what
after everyone it's great
Perl tries to make every expression you
write do something awk would do the same
kind of casting traditional scripting
language languages thought that loose
types were convenient
they were wrong the truth is that Lewis
types are terrible they break a
principle that I'll call locality when
you have an error in your program it's
nice to have a exception raised close to
where you made the error the problem
with all of that crazy casting where you
know in JavaScript almost any expression
will evaluate to something is that if
you make a mistake in the middle of your
program it will run to completion and
nonsense will print out and you won't
know until you do a line by line search
where you made the error it also hurts
readability because secret casting is
when you go back later to maintain the
program happening in the middle of a
line where there's a plus statement with
no indication unless you've left a
comment that a value is being cast to do
another in Python we believe that both
of these as they would be in C++ deserve
to simply be errors because it's easy
enough to turn to ask for the string for
to become an integer
maybe someone type that in and you need
to interpret it or to have three turned
into a string this code is readable you
can maintain it later it makes clear to
you all the steps that are taking place
to compute the output value in Python we
believe that explicit is better than
implicit and that errors should never
pass silently we want to show you the
line of code where you did something
nonsensical instead of showing you
nonsense when the program ends Python
uses a strict type system where for the
most part the only casting is we will
let you add a float to an int without an
explicit cast though even some days
we're sad we did that because they can
confuse people that don't understand the
limits of those two types
so we're going to clean off that whole
mess of how scripting languages
traditionally did math and it's time now
to think about what variables are going
to mean in C++ you have a range of
options from having values living as
automatics right on the stack all the
way out to the stack simply holding a
pointer and the value being out in
memory for many of the tasks C++ is used
for it's important to be in control of
that distinction what if we just want to
do one thing for Python and to make it
work
obviously you can't use pass by value
huge data structures don't like being
copied onto the stack so in Python we're
only going to use pointers we're going
to do a massive simplification and
decide that every variable is a pointer
to an object without exception if you
say I equals three a integer object is
created on the heap with three written
in its bits and your name a is made a
pointer to it B equals a is a point or
copying operation you now have two names
that hold the same pointer if everything
is a pointer how many list types are we
going to need to write in Python
one if Python comes with a list of
pointers type you're done with lists you
can have a list of integers strings
floats other lists whatever you want as
long as you have a list of pointers
because everything is a pointer
how many hash table types do we need
hashmaps what Python calls the
dictionary or dict one that map's keys
that are pointers to values to values
that are pointers to objects out on the
heap this means that the entire section
of the C++ specification on templates
evaporates because all types that you
write all container types are
automatically eligible to hold any
objects by virtue of the fact that a
container simply holds the pointers
always I don't mean always Python comes
with like you know efficient float
arrays that you can use if you're a data
scientist or doing statistics but the
bare language a equals three is always
using pointers everything a pointer
means that data structures are not only
simple and you only need one of each of
them it also means that they're
automatically composable what if you
wanted maybe because you were reading
from an API out on the web what if you
wanted a list each of whose elements is
a dictionary you just type it and it
works for free the fact that everything
that the fact that all little list
stores is pointers means that you could
build this compound data structure
without declaring anything asking
permission it just works
Oh what what if you want a dictionary
whose values are lists instead of simple
strings or integers you just type it and
it works
okay what if you want compound hashmap
keys I cheated a little by having that
previous slide have the values you can't
use lists for the keys because a list
can grow or shrink or have elements
added or removed that would change its
hash value which means that you wouldn't
find it when you came back to the hash
map hashmaps only work with items whose
hash value is stable so Python comes
with a second built-in sequence that is
immutable calls it a tupple a tuple
topple I don't know English you use
parens instead of square brackets and
once you've set it up it can never
change this means it has a stable hash
value and can be used as a compound key
by the fact that a few of you do not
look immensely excited I can tell that
you have never tried using a scripting
language that only allowed string keys
to its hashmap tuple dictionary keys
solve instantly a terrible old problem
in scripting which was let's say that
I'm collating output we use it work
several different lenders and then we
have to bring all the information
together to show it to the developer and
let's say that the keys into a file are
kind of heterogeneous they're a file
name and the line that the linter
message is about if we're not Alif we
don't have a way to create compound hash
keys we're gonna have to munch all of
the information together into a single
value you pick some delimiter you turn
the integer from being an integer into a
series of digits and you can kind of
mush everything together and it works
great until you encounter your first
file with a colon in the name and then
it breaks and then you go back in and
you remember all right we look for the
colon from the right so it's okay if
there are other colons in there and then
it keeps working for a while then you're
ready to sort these messages to show
them to the user and it sorts in this
order with eight
later than 47 oh that's because it's
using alphabetical order it's going you
know like these are words and it gets to
the four and the eight and puts a four
alphabetically first and so I ever done
this you then have to add zero padding
but you can only do so many zeros this
is going to fail if I ever have to lint
a million line file I hope they never
try to do that with my ox script or
whatever all of that is avoided if your
type system gives you a hashable
compound type that lets you put several
pieces of information together in a
tight little package tuples and lists
not only support hashing they support
sorting and this is really fun because
they sort like a spreadsheet would if
you've ever gone into a spreadsheet and
sorted by several columns when you sort
if the first item wins the sorting
contest that determines the order but if
two items have the same first item the
sorting goes to the second so you very
very naturally can collate heterogeneous
data last names and first names in this
host names and port numbers by simply
putting them into tuples and running
sort because we have tuples all right
well that lets us return multiple values
something that c and c++ inexplicably
didn't allow even though it's a stack
you can put as much stuff on it as you
want when you return go allows it but
not historically allowed in C and C++
and we went ahead and it's so so common
to return several values that we added
to the assignment statement the ability
to unpack a tuple into several names so
that you don't have to use a single name
and an index address to find the first
and the second thing in that sequence a
side effect is that swapping becomes a
single line this is less important than
I used to think I was so excited about
this when I saw Python in the 90s
because in the languages I had been
using it always took at least three
lines
in order to do a swap because you had to
have a temporary variable I mean okay or
you could use semicolons put them all on
one line but the point is it becomes
trivially simple if creating little
bundles of information and out of names
and unpacking them back into names are
both natively supported by your syntax
in fact everything is a pointer means
functions and types can become eligible
data who has ever seen the design
patterns book by the Gang of Four
several of you it has all kinds of
complicated ways because it is
complicated in some languages to try to
parameterize the choice of an object by
data at runtime how do you let a piece
of data choose which type you
instantiate or what you routine you call
since functions are simply objects with
an address and remember hashmaps can
hold addresses it is very V all of those
gang of four patterns evaporate in
Python and never take place because it's
very very easy simply when you need to
to treat functions as data put them in a
data structure pull them out later and
call them you can also put types because
they have an address into a hash map and
let data at runtime let you decide what
class to instantiate David wheeler once
famously said all problems in computer
science can be solved by another level
of indirection you can think of Python
as your friendly level of indirection as
C++ but we're again instead of forcing
you at every moment to be thinking about
we're along a continuum of automatic to
a pointer and heap you want to put each
piece of information it encourages you
to simply when you first write your
program until you've compiled it and
found if there's genuinely a hotspot in
there it encourages you to simply use
and everything is a pointer level of
indirection
and so many problems in computing
suddenly become much simpler everything
is a pointer all right what are these
pointers going to point at what
uniformity can we create in the things
pointed to C++ has many types I know
something simpler we can do let's have
one type people who do type algebra
always shake their heads and say Python
just has one type I think that's a good
thing because it creates uniformity
which again makes the language very
simple every single Python object now
understand I'm kind of lying I'm talking
about the basic version of Python called
C Python written in C that you would
download from Python website the things
I'm about to say are true of it they are
not true of pi pi the just-in-time
compiled version of Python where all the
objects disappear and it becomes unboxed
floats and intz on the stack anyway this
isn't true of versions of Python that
run on the JVM it's not true of a micro
Python which was recently created for
the little computers that are handed out
now to British schoolchildren where many
of these types small integers small
strings are just stuck directly into the
pointer hey bits is a lot but eight bits
eight bytes is a lot right why not just
store all your data in the pointer those
lower two bits are always zero anyway
why not just use them to encode hey this
isn't really a pointer this is the
integer itself I am describing I what
I'm doing in this talk is I'm using the
basic simple version of Python that's
always been the standard when you
download from the website the one that
interfaces with C and C++ the most
seamlessly
I'm using it to build for us a mental
model of pythons simplicity which I can
explain so simply because I'm talking to
an audience many of whom know about
pointers addresses and will recognize a
struct that at the top of it has a
pointer to the type of the information
that follows Python the language runtime
is not very opinionated about what comes
after that type object pointer all it
requires is that all of these pointers
pointing to Python values start with
depending on your platform four or eight
bytes of pointer that gets Python to a
type object which tell tells Python the
rest of what it needs to know about that
object
what does type object look like it is
all of the abilities that an integer a
float a string or a custom type needs to
have in order to have all of Python
syntax + - item lookup occur it has a
get outer set adder in case you try
using index lookup using square brackets
it has new because you need to create
them it has free because you need to get
rid of them add and subtract because you
might use plus and minus rich compares
so that you can do greater than and less
than each type implements on pythons
behalf the operations that know how to
get into that payload that follows the
type pointer and interpret it correctly
to do all of the things an integer or a
string should this is a radical
difference I will admit from C++ and C++
types belong to names int a equals 3 it
is a that is an int in Python types
instead R on the other side of the fence
they belong to values a is just a
pointer the type is out on the thing
pointed to that's why it's called a
dynamic language that's the definition
we're only going to support two-pointer
operations one and you'll know they are
both entirely safe operations is copying
you can say a equals B and make a copy
of the pointer or copy the pointer into
the slot of a list or copy the pointers
to a pair of strings into a
corresponding key and value in a hashmap
copying pointers can never affect the
safety of course of your program copying
is safe second the only other thing you
can do is call one of those methods in
the type object Python code can only
interact with a built-in object an
integer
stirring through its methods which means
there's no danger that anything your
your Python program might hit an error
and crash and get a nice trace back but
it is never going to corrupt memory
because you can't get inside of those
objects you can only ask their methods
they are fully encapsulated ask their
methods to go and perform operations on
them a question that might be latent in
a few of your heads so I'll answer it is
well wait a minute
if when you say in is 3 you now have a
pointer to an object 3 out on the heap
and then I pass it to some function as I
wanted to do I pass in if it's a pointer
what is to stop some function from
changing what my variable in means it
means 3 for me before I call the
function what's to stop my strings and
integers and floats from just suddenly
changing them of changing their value
after I've passed them to someone the
answer is that Python only lets you call
methods and int float and stir choose to
be implemented as read-only
they don't implement a set operation
once you have a three it will remain
three because you have no way to touch
it or change it until it is finally be
allocated immutable int float and string
provide the semantics of C++ automatic
variables where you say in equals three
and expect it to stay there in and
everything is a pointer language where
things might have been otherwise had it
not been as carefully designed uniform
types and methods by the way as we saw
in that type object make generic
operations easy men max some are all
just built-ins you don't even have to
import them they're always in scope and
you can call them and they work
seamlessly on any kind of value that
implements in equality for men and Max
or addition for some so we've described
what objects look like how do you create
them this is a question of syntax
because of course C++ for example has
three at least three different ways to
get an object created and instantiated
well if you've you've seen my pattern so
far as you could guess we're going to
choose one of these looking at these you
know from your Gang of Four book that
the factory the arbitrary callable
that's going to give you back a pointer
is the most general that can apply to
the most situations of all three of
these patterns so Python chooses that
one the only creation pattern Python
supports is the factory where you call a
function and you get back an object
factories have the additional happiness
in a language where we want the syntax
to be as simple as possible
that it requires no additional syntax we
already support the function call with
parens a factory just happens to be a
function that returns a new object
rather than an old one and what we're
going to do you already saw this though
it passed fairly quickly when I did
typecasting earlier the rule is this
we're going to make each type its own
factory you can of course go write as
many other factories as you want that
that do interesting and custom things
while creating an object but int the
type int is callable like it's a
function and it builds integers
interpreted from the input that you give
it float stir or homemade classes you
write yourself all support the factory
pattern they are callable that give you
an object with no additional syntax we
support arbitrary complexity and how
objects behind the scenes are created
because we did use a great idea from C++
you saw it earlier that each type
defines how its new operation works this
lets us use arenas and I apologize for
peaky speaking previously as though we
go malloc and integer when you say 3
that would be silly
don't call malloc integers since they're
all and unless they're very big ones
like 2 to the 257 the power since
integers mostly fit into 32 or 64 bits
we go ahead and we do a single malloc of
say a thousand integers thousand little
Struck's already to hold an integer
that's called an arena that's used in
C++ as well so as you're asking for new
integers to be created with math they're
often just sticking their value into a
premade integer object whose address
you're returned this also lets us
implement flywheels when python
initializes it goes ahead and pre
creates the integers well it depends on
the implementation c python negative 12
through 256 are pre created as little
flywheel objects
that's a Gang of Four
where if I say in equals three it
doesn't really go create a new three it
just hands me the three object it always
has sitting around because small
integers turn up so often in programming
what about no it creates complexity so
nope we outlined the syntax provides no
mechanism for creating a null pointer
this means that unless a c library
you're using misbehaves segmentation
faults become impossible I pretty much
haven't seen one in twenty years of my
Python coding buffer overflows I mean
you can run out of memory but because
you're never creating fixed buffers that
you're pointing i/o operations at buffer
overflows thereby become impossible
thereby eliminating two of the major
sources of large security problems in
software over the last two to three
decades but wait I can hear you say if
the type struct that I showed you is
fixed has a set number of operations
how are users going to write their
classes where they want to create new
methods that they name where they also
will want to be able to create
attributes of their own like host and
port in this simple example the magic is
that we create a base class a base type
for all user classes whose get adder set
adder and new do something simple new
creates a hash table a dictionary set
adder put something in the dictionary
and get adder gets something out user
classes are allowed to have whatever
methods whatever attributes they want
because they're not backed by sea level
structs they're backed unless you do
special things to increase the
performance
by a hash-table what of the concepts and
all of the rules in C++ around private
and protected for a scripting language
we're going to throw them overboard we
already have in the built-in types other
privacy utter encapsulation where it
really really counts language integrity
in Python is considered the only excuse
for hiding details
intz floats and strings don't let you
manipulate their bits they are opaque
user class attributes however are
entirely public you can put an
underscore in front of one of them to
warn people away from it but Python made
a big bet for the early 90s when when
protection was a big deal back then
there was this belief but the reason we
write big buggy software that falls over
is because we don't have enough private
variables I think that 20 years private
variables have shown that that's not the
only reason we were writing big software
that falls over Python elected to not
even opt into the complexity and it
hasn't ever really hurt us alright
memory management alright if we're
creating things out on the heap for
integers floats when do they go away we
chose the most general pattern we could
find that had good and immediate
performance and predictable behavior
everything is a shared pointer that
means that the earlier struct I showed
you was a lie but a necessary lie
because a talk must tackle its topics in
some order in fact there is also a
reference count in C Python not in all
other implementations but in the simple
version that uses malloc and can
interact with your C code there is a
reference count as well at the top of
every single object when the reference
count drops to zero that is when you
know it is safe to deallocate reference
counting is kind of nice in a lot of
ways it is instant as soon as the count
drops to zero memory is freed it also
provide provides good locality
garbage collection as this horrible
problem that is you're creating lots and
lots of new objects they're all getting
created out in new memory that is not in
your processors cache yet leaving
stranded in your cache all of the
objects that you're done with but the
garbage collector is not going to
discover for a few seconds because the
garbage collector tends to come along a
good deal behind you in discovering when
things are freed reference counting can
give you a runtime that in many cases
has very good performance because yes
you might be boxing everything in a
struct but you're often using again the
integer you just freed for the next
integer you produce so it's still
sitting in the cache and if you've heard
any talks lately on processor
performance you know that in most
applications processors these days are
not doing anything they're sitting
blocked on the level 1 into cache so we
found reference counting is it's just
simple predictable it doesn't tend to
grind the program to a halt randomly
doesn't use lots of extra memory because
things are freed immediately again
caveat all that I'm saying is only true
of our runtime that's built to interact
with C micro Python has other approaches
to pointers and in pi PI Jitsu you know
it runs a loop a few times as wait a
minute these are all integers and
compiles it down to integer machine code
instead however no matter how smart one
of these implementations tries to get
the mental model I am building for you
of this simplification of programming
always applies it is always ok to think
about your program as names and values
pointers to objects even if some
runtimes are going to secretly stop
using objects when they know it's safe
what then in our attempt to create a
simple programming language for everyone
but they but yet that is powerful enough
for professionals what are the patterns
that we got wrong as we tried to figure
out how to use the new set of tools we
created first the Python 2 type system
which did become even stronger in Python
3 had some problems in it we thought you
know examples I showed you loose type
systems we rolled our eyes and tried to
do better and failed we fixed a lot of
problems but for example we Python 2 if
you try to combine a plane byte string
with a Unicode string that can have you
know several byte characters it would
just go ahead and without asking coerce
the byte string using I think whatever
the local encoding was when Python
started to a Unicode string this is
exactly the problem with websites
written in Python 2 is they work a great
in English they do not tend to work well
once they are encountering byte strings
that converted to Unicode just fine
using a westcoast you know type set when
only Americans were using it but then
they break when this automatic
conversion is beginning to get binary
bytes in those incoming strings when
people are typing their names so in
Python 3 it was adjusted to the bottom
example it is now a type error like we
now recognize it always should have been
back in Python 2 something slipped
through comparisons if they were given
completely different kinds of things
which just put all the integers on one
side and all the strings on another this
means when a naive program puts a bunch
of numbers in a list not realizing that
some of them are strings and some are in
scuzz the programmer isn't quite learned
yet they come out in a surprising order
instead of doing what python really says
it should which is raising an exception
to let you know you
something nonsensical Python 3 took away
from all of its inequality operations
any willingness except again for floats
and ents it will compare those but
otherwise it stops and tells you that
you've asked it to compare unalike
things so that you can go in one way or
the other and explicitly fix your
sequence finally programmers given a
dynamic language overused dynamic miss
and Wow especially back in the 90s they
did it a lot so for example here even if
port is is none we still waste an
attribute storing it some Python
programmers of the 90s thought wait a
minute wait a minute
how about if they pass in a port of none
I could even make it an optional
arguments they don't have to pass it
then I won't even store a port attribute
and you suddenly had running around
memory address objects that didn't all
look the same that you couldn't all
touch with the same logic because they
were asymmetric some had dot port
attributes and some did not suddenly you
couldn't even go touch a dot port
without checking first whether it has
that attribute that's a bad sign in
modern Python code if you see the has a
derp test being run what you want to do
in modern Python today is best practice
is to make every attribute always
present if you're ever gonna have a dot
port go ahead and always have one it's
much simpler syntactically instead of
backing up to ask the metasyntactic
question does this have a dot port
attribute to instead be able to assume
that it does and ask the kind of in
language question hey adder dot port are
you the value none
so with respect to the stability of a
classes attribute lists Python's classes
have gone back in practice to being just
like c++ early experiments and having
attribute lists expand and contract are
gone we now just want our objects to
work like in C++
another bad habit was that Python
routines that tried to support often try
to support many argument types instead
of just one it's very tempting you can
say oh it's so much trouble for the
person to send me a list of strings if
they just send me one string I'll split
it apart if I find commas inside problem
is if the person calls it in a way that
they don't mean to that can keep the
program running even when they didn't
mean for the single string they passed
you to be taken as a list of columns and
it also makes code that supports several
types can be tempting because of
convenience but it's harder to test
there's more directions that can go in
and even going you can have 100%
coverage on a piece of code but you only
run it with one of the types the
programmer sends it there aren't any
coverage programs that will tell you if
you call it three times for all three
different types that it might be called
with it's hard to test code that's
designed to take multiple types it's
terrible harder to modify it because you
often don't know that three different
types could be attached to the name that
you're looking at and it's harder to
debug so once again python has the
possibility of passing whatever you want
to a function all practicing Python
coders I know are doing exactly what
happens in C++ if there is something
called port it always has the same type
in their program always an integer and
that practice essentially represents an
experiment in dynamic programming or in
a dynamic language
and deciding that that wasn't one of the
benefits of a dynamic language and it's
been rolled back to the practice that
standard in C++ and C it's usually a
design bug
if you ever in python need to call eval
it always means that you're missing some
simpler pattern that would let you do it
in real code unless and this is pythons
great glory unless you're writing a
language server
unless you're implementing the ipython
notebook and want people to be able to
type Python expressions into a website
where they're working on a data problem
and run those then you're very happy you
chose Python because it's a little
harder in C++ to accept fresh C++ X
statements from a website and run them
what in general then is the value of
introspection we added it to the
language but it's not really useful in
application code of get adder has adder
is instance what is your type Python
support for introspection has turned out
to be a huge win for what I'll call code
that's about code loggers lenders
debuggers testers often become simple to
write it's so easy to tool up a project
with custom tools you don't want to be
using these things in your application
code but they make writing code that
handles other code much simpler I'll end
by saying that we are living through a
great age of consolidation of
programming practice 20 years ago I
couldn't have said shared pointer and
with a single name communicated to every
C++ programmer the way that Python does
reference counting today I can best
practices are flying back and forth
between different language communities
for loops are starting to become more
powerful in go in Python and in C++ over
the 90s and 2000's and beyond
in order to try to get a measurement of
that I looked at the great C++ project
tensorflow
for a lot of the kids I now coming out
of college today I think they think C++
is simply tensor flows build system
probably most of the C++ at least on the
west coast most of the CPU time it
spends today will be compiling
tensorflow yet again build systems and
tensorflow
anyway I got tensorflow
this is very small but these are dates
along the bottom from early 2016 to 2018
I wrote I didn't write in Python I wrote
it in shell a little program that
stepped through a number of versions of
sensor flow and computed the number of
lines of C++ and the number of lines of
C++ that we're using shared pointer this
is not a total number of lines of course
that's going up tensorflow is getting
bigger every week this is the fraction
of lines in tensorflow
that are declaring a shared pointer and
look at that in good Silicon Valley
style that is a line that goes where up
and to the right
where is C++ going we talked at the
beginning about a limiting case what
happens according to that graph we just
saw as T goes to infinity everything is
going to become a shared pointer in the
end even C++ becomes Python
thank you very much
[Applause]
you